there's about two percent of the
population's autistic
but it's really only in the last 20
years that they really properly started
diagnosing people and so if you go back
in time if you're in your 30s and up
there's there's a whole population of
people that have never been diagnosed
that have no idea they're autistic and
once you realize it it's like so many
things make sense to you and so you're
like oh you should like relive all of
your life events and all your successes
and failures and I I can tie almost
everything back to that
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders today I'm
with Peter Mann the CEO and founder of
virginia-based oronsi a leading air
purification company known for its
efficient intuitive and reliable
products for consumers schools
organizations and businesses he also is
the chair of the association of Home
Appliance manufacturers and in 2021
merged with avimore Technologies and is
now a motor technology company with a
clean energy Mission Iran's new
manufacturing facility in Radford
Virginia is making products in the
United States with Advanced Motor
Technologies previously he was the
founder and CEO of the Austin
texas-based Allen Corp an air
purification company he built and after
seven years had a successful exit he
went to college on a Navy ROTC
scholarship and then served four years
including a tour in the Red Sea during
the first Gulf War
Peter Mann welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for being here how are
you I'm doing great thanks Michael for
having me thank you very much for
joining me today I'm really excited to
you know get to know you and and your
journey and talk a little bit about
something that I that I I'm not used to
talking about but I'm ex I'm looking
forward to getting excited about it
through your own lenses air purification
and also from an entrepreneurship and
Leadership angle so again thank you for
for spending this time with me
let's just start you know right where
the elephant is you know air
purification how how does one get into
yeah how does one get into this industry
yeah so I got started about 20 years ago
and it was when
um my son suffered with asthma and so
just you know kind of
you know um you know watching him not
breathe and change color kind of left an
impression on me and
um you know the normal route is she go
to the doctor and they give you steroids
or you know things like that which have
side effects which aren't great and so
you know I was like gosh there's got to
be maybe some way to maybe lessen his
asthma attacks and so I started
um you know around 2002 looking into air
purification
um and at that time I was at Dell I was
uh
senior manager over the software and
peripherals group and so we managed
everything but the computers from a
marketing standpoint so that would be
the printers the
um you know consumables you know
everything monitors all that kind of
stuff and I started an e-commerce
business at night with another guy in
Austin and after about six months it got
to where I didn't need to work at Dell
anymore
um you know I had no MBA or business
classes in college I was more
engineering and so I'm like I really
don't know what I'm getting into but it
was a way to get started without you
know having so much risk it was just you
just put in more time it was you know my
7 to 11 pm job
um until it got going and then I left
and
um and it really got it started by just
reselling other people's air purifier
products to really learn the market and
then after a couple years
um connected with some Chinese factories
and and started to Brand our own
products
wow
and
right before when we're going to dive
into to this a little bit later and what
you're doing specifically and
specifically today with Iran c
um you know one of the you know I
generally don't don't the fun fact is
for the uh you know more for the for the
metadata or the description of the show
but here I I'd love to understand a
little bit better you know you you wrote
that you were late diagnosed with with
autism and that you spend all so much of
your time
um raising awareness of for autism in
the workplace I'd love to learn a little
bit about that
yeah this is um
this this is an interesting one I just
realized this it was about a year ago
wow my wife was watching she was in the
kitchen in the I don't know CBS Morning
Show is on and they had uh a profile of
I think it was maybe a NASA employee and
she was talking about some of her traits
and characteristics and she said you
need to watch this this sounds just like
you in terms of being able to hyper
Focus being able to see patterns or see
changes that maybe other people don't
pick up
the need for routines and I was like oh
wow that's in and so then I went online
and I took several tests and you know
there's a scale and it's like oh yeah
you're very likely autistic and it it
was really just the most remarkable
thing because I had no idea wow and
that's what I've come to learn is that's
a pretty common thing you know there's
about two percent of the populations
autistic but it's really only in the
last 20 years that they really properly
started diagnosing people and so if you
go back in time if you're in your 30s
and up there's there's a whole
population of people that have never
been diagnosed that have no idea they're
autistic and once you realize it it's
like so many things make sense to you
and so you're like oh
you like relive all of your life events
and all your successes and failures and
I I can tie almost everything back to
that
right it's I don't know it's it's it's
pretty life-changing and I I bet there's
people listening to your podcast that if
they're in their 30s and up
um it could be half a percent to one
percent or artistic and don't know it
well how does that did that change
anything knowing it you know how did
that impact
yeah it well it
it helps a lot because it helps set
expectations with people in terms of
um you know how I work or how I interact
with people or expectations or on social
interactions and
um you know it's it's more of the issue
is like what I learned is like between
autistic people there's no issues with
communication but the issue is between
autistic and non-autistic people is
where the
conflictorizes the problem is autistic
people are only about two percent of the
population so you're you're you're the
minority
um and you're kind of deemed as doing
things the wrong way when it's really
just a different way it's not
you know it's it's this rigidity that
that's in place and I I kind of see that
now and so it's to me it's just
I don't know how to say it other than
this is completely life-altering just
having that recognition
and so how do you now navigate
um whether it's in the workplace or
anything else how what what navigation
does this help you now to sort of
mitigate the the the the gap between
perhaps the expectations and reality
um you know what what are some helpful
yeah so I'm kind of fortunate where like
um a lot a lot of folks who are autistic
are afraid to speak up and say it
because it's so stigmatized but I'm in a
position where it's like I don't have
any hesitation telling someone or if so
something's happening that doesn't work
with me I have no issue speaking up for
myself and saying you know this
environment's not not working
um then this is why
um and then people are like oh yeah I
get it no no problem but
um
I don't know I could probably talk for a
couple hours around around the
idiosyncrasies of it but it I think just
having the awareness and having others
around me have the awareness it you know
but you know it's just so much better
yeah no I I bet well this is a it's a
fascinating it's a fascinating subject
so and thank you for the cabiness and
the and the authenticity tell me a
little bit about about oranazi and uh
and and what you've built over the last
13 years
yeah so I started this business in so
the e-commerce business I referred to
earlier uh I sold to my business partner
in 2009 and I started this as a brand
um you know initially to to make air
purifiers and um you know it's kind of
evolved over time and it really took a
life of its own with covet hit
um it was you know most people are like
uh whatever about HEPA air purifiers but
when kovid hit it was it just went
insane in terms of the demand
um for the product
um and so many new brands getting into
the space it's you know before there
there weren't a lot of brands in the air
purifier space but on covet head it's
it's like doubled
um it's and it's it's been really
interesting to watch just it's
um you know it's a really big Brands get
into the space but for us
um you know you know one of the things
about being autistic is you tend to be
more on the Innovation side and really
digging into the details and looking for
the opportunities and I've been working
on this for several years but we
partnered or merged with a electric
motor company in Radford Virginia
about a year and a half ago and that's
really I think going to put us on a
different trajectory going forward to
where we have a new motor technology and
and really going to base a whole series
of products off of that platform made in
Virginia
the the biggest challenge with made in
USA is you know consumer reports and
Reuters did some surveys and they found
between 70 and 80 percent of people
prefer American-made products but most
don't want to pay any premium and so
that's that's the challenge and so
that's that's what we've solved for and
that's what I'm really excited about for
2023 and going forward is
um we've kind of gone back and
redesigned some products and
come up in the new way to make electric
motors that allows us to really compete
very well with the any any Import in
terms of price or performance
tell me a little bit about building a
brand uh for cons for direct to Consumer
you know what what what what what was
that like what did you find successful
what did you find challenging in
creating a brand that needs to create
obviously trust and it sounds like this
is something that's a pretty big it's a
pretty big game not just a financially
wise which is it's also a big Financial
purchase but it but it requires also
some commitment from the from the
customers to buy into your technology to
buy into your brand and and trust you
yeah I mean It's tricky because in the
marketplace the customers don't really
care about you you have to you have to
like earn their trust and
um what I would say is what what we did
when we started you know we started with
it from just you know there's just three
of us and
um
we outsourced a number of functions of
it like Tim ferriss's four hour work
week it's like oh you just kind of five
people in the outsourced and there's a
lot of services right now where you can
Outsource a lot of a lot of things as a
brand but the one thing we didn't
Outsource was customer service and so
um with with our products you know we
made the phone number prevalent the
demographic tends to skew a bit older
it's people that buy air purifiers or
people with the weaker respiratory
systems and so it's it's a
more likely a senior citizen or it's
maybe a young mom with a child
and so we we knew who our audience was
and we spoke to them we addressed their
concerns and we were like a human being
to them and people really appreciate it
like you call and somebody answers the
phone and that can answer your questions
and guide you through and if we weren't
the right product we would direct them
to it to a different brand that says you
know what what you're looking for is a
little bit outside the scope of what we
do we suggest you go with this product
because we know the market and and
people like that and they talk about it
and so you know that's that's really
kind of what we've been about is really
just taking care of customers
um Above All Else
how do you think your own personal
experience with your son and sort of
impacted that
yeah because we we build products that
are you know um
do do what they we
and they do what we say they do
um and they're safe there's a lot of I
would just call it like snake oil out
there where people are trying to make a
quick buck and to me it's really
unethical it's somebody that has a
respiratory issue and you're you're
trying to you know clean the air for
them
um and so
um I mean for us it's just being
truthful about what what the product
does and answering the customers
questions is is this simple
um but it's shocking how
um many people or other brands don't
really know the market or know what what
they're selling they're just it's almost
like any other Appliance
yeah and and and from my perspective of
having a son who suffered with asthma is
like this is not just an appliance if it
works well
100 what are the you know benefit the
benefits that you reap as an
organization we'll say from
high integrity and high trust in what
you're representing how do you now you
sort of you as a leader of the
organization how does this impact the
the experience the journey
for the I guess I'm not sure for the
customer or before oranzi for the Oracle
yeah to me it's it's really rewarding
um you know I just know like
from a marketing standpoint
um if you can be honest and customers
like you they'll talk about you and you
want them to talk about you favorably
and it's just rewarding to see the
reviews and see how people's lives have
been impacted for the positive and if
there is you know you know very rare
exception someone has an issue we you
know always bend to the benefit of the
customer
it's kind of like treat your customer
like you would like to be treated and
the rest takes care of itself
yeah what's the vision of the company
the vision is we are uh so right now
we're really uh transitioning we're kind
of back to a startup mode with what
we're doing after the mergers so uh
we're gonna
um
electric motor technology company with a
sustainable Mission and so we're
reshoring or manufacturing we're going
to make our Motors and our air purifiers
in-house with probably 90 plus of the
content Source locally
um in terms of raw materials or Plastics
and things like that that go into the
product and we're really about
you know really being a market leader
but driving
um performance I mean you know price is
important so
um the other thing I see happening is
with our technology
um and I grew up
um and you know in the 80s and you know
computer programming and it was kind of
interesting at that time there are a lot
of folks that were like oh computers
will never be anything or you know it
was even before the internet was a
thought and you know that industry
really took off and what I see now is
clean energy is really the next Big
Industry especially with climate change
and I think the motor technology we have
is going to play a critical role in the
move to electrification since what we've
built has higher performance and lower
costs than the existing Motors on the
marketplace
yeah that makes sense
tell me a little bit about the
technology
yeah what's happening in air
purification systems I think this will
be fascinating to a lot of listeners
what yeah I mean so air cleaning is
really not very complicated it's
understanding concept it's really just
about moving enough air for the size of
your space and then filtering out what
passes through the filters I mean it's
pretty simple
of a concept but it's difficult to do in
practice because there's noise there's
how big's your space and are you moving
enough air and do you have proper
filters
um but the uh but that's the challenge
everyone the faces and you know the HEPA
filter is really the best technology for
removing particulates which is mainly
what people want removed and
um you know that technology has been
around for 40 50 years so it's kind of
interesting that what works is what's
been around a long time and what we're
seeing is some new technologies come out
but if you listen to The Experts that's
it's all unproven and not as effective
and so what we're focused on is what
works which is
um you know just have the filtration
and from the energy conscious side
from a sustainability approach you
mentioned something about that well what
what did you mean by that
yeah so in terms of restoring or
manufacturing
um we're really doing a couple things
and sustainability is a big part of it
is in in US manufacturing the products
here and then we Ship Direct to the end
user we're really shrinking the supply
chain to to our facility for the most
part in some local suppliers and so it's
not being made in China under who knows
what conditions and then shipped across
the ocean which adds pollution and then
shipped
three times in the U.S it's like it's if
it's as efficient as possible and we're
just reducing
you know every step possible in doing it
you know pretty much the entire thing
ourselves and so from a sustainability
standpoint we're making it to the U.S
environmental standards we have minimal
waste and and in terms of shipping which
you know there's pollution involved in
there we've minimized that as well so I
think
from a sustainability we've got a pretty
strong story and we're doing it at a
going to be doing it at a price point
that's going to be competitive it
doesn't have the green premium which is
a which is a problem for a lot of
us-made products I love it so you know
you kind of answered this throughout
um throughout the show but I but it's
still my favorite question you know kind
of you know where is the the big moments
of delight that you get in your
day-to-day
so
um
I just like the process I don't know if
there's any one moment I just like doing
the work that's the you know interesting
thing
um about being autistic is I get
dopamine from just working it doesn't
have to be anything big it's just like
if I'm working on the business I'm
excited or if I'm learning about
something that could help the business
or help customers then then I'm very
interested in that and so
um
I don't know it's I I don't know how
else to answer it but it's it's just the
work itself in the process is to me
what's fun
well I I really want to thank you for
your time and for the insights and the
the openness and authenticity this is a
really enjoyable conversation for me and
I'm wishing you best of luck with the
future of aranzi and uh and everything
else that you'll do and so thank you
thank you again Peter and I'm gonna
continue chewing from the side and stay
safe and stay healthy all right thanks
Michael I've enjoyed it thank you
foreign
[Music]